ted wheeler
has now been trending on twitter uh
always interesting when ted wheeler is
trending on twitter
um he's trending on twitter and this
time you know i
always click with some trepidation uh
went in
how do you do now right and in this case
i was actually
quite surprised and relieved to find
that in effect what he has
finally said and as you pointed out in a
conversation earlier it's not the first
time he said something like this
but he has said it and then reneged on
it and in this case
maybe maybe he's finally grown aware but
what he's effectively said is that
portland has a serious problem with
anarchists
that these are uh
law breakers who must be arrested
um and that is something that he has
been
very very timid about and so
he has extended a state of emergency
through the weekend
and he has instructed the police and i
should point out that it is are we going
to show the videos or
yeah i think we should i think we should
show the videos i should point out that
in
portland we have the odd fact of our
mayor
also being our police commissioner
which means that what he says about what
the police should do carries more weight
than it might in some other city
um so all right zach do you want to uh
show the first
they're not they're not the same video
they're two different videos do you want
to show both of them or do you want just
why not the one that you sent zach okay
so in so hold on just a second zack then
uh in a slightly longer video from uh
coin six which is a local cbs affiliate
i think it's cbs the cbs the one with
the i
yes i honestly i went to their site i
was like i think this is cbs's logo
there's nothing on the site that says
cbs anywhere like they just assume we
know that that crazy scary looking eye
is cbs
anyway that's a different different
topic but
um one of the newscasters says
with regard to antifa's or the
anarchists i'm not even sure who now is
claiming to be doing these things
um they keep on making these um
these announcements in advance they're
going to do these direct actions right
and so the newscaster says in the past
events billed as direct
action have ended with violence and
destruction so that's now showing up on
the news
yep that is now showing up in the news
finally
and now we have this um shorter video
zach the one minute four second one or
so
and i've extended the state of emergency
through the weekend
our job is to unmask them
arrest them and prosecute them
i want to personally thank neighbors
family
friends and others who've come forward
with vital evidence
people know who these criminals are they
know what they're up to
if you have any information please
contact the police
acting chief davis will provide
specifics shortly
i also want you to know that these
people often arrive
at their so-called direct actions
in cars and they're all dressed in all
black
if you see this call the police
if you can provide a license plate if
you can do so safely
that information can help later
together we can make a stand
we're doing what we can today i'm also
asking for your help
to make you stand and take our city back
thank you
okay um so let's
first of all i just want to uh address
the elephant in the room as it were
actually that may turn out to be a
better metaphor in this case
than uh than i had anticipated but sure
it's not donkey
it is the elephant in the room in this
case um so
i do not know whether or not we are
having an impact
on for example ted wheeler's
understanding
of what's going on i do know that this
week
i had a piece in unheard which is a
british publication
on what's going on in portland and of
the absurd
fact of local businesses
putting signage in their window which
you have called don't hurt me walls
that appear to attempt to usher vandals
on
to harm someone else all right
obvious game theoretic hazard of the
civilian authority
not only taking no stand
but hobbling the the police and the
enforcement of the law
i do think that there is a strong chance
we are constantly facing
calls that we um you know admit that the
conservatives are right
that we acknowledge that we are
conservatives or something like this
um and i think this
um we've never done this because we're
not conservatives and
while the conservatives are in many
cases defending principles that are
traditionally liberal in this case where
liberals have abandoned them
the fact of those principles having been
innovated by liberals
is an important part of the story in any
case
i i just want to say we don't know
whether we're having an effect but i
think it is very important and likely to
be having an effect
that people who are local to portland
who are not interested
in mocking it as a terrible place and
people who are not interested in mocking
liberalism itself are saying hey
actually this is an untenable situation
um and that the
the fact is the violence itself
has adjusted what people
acknowledge you and i meet people all
the time who say very standard things
about their belief until we say
non-standard things at which point we
get confessions about what they actually
think right here in portland
yeah you're in portland and so no doubt
mayor wheeler is getting some of the
same many people show up in our email
and comments and such as well from
portland
right saying thank you for saying for
for saying things that sound like the
conversation's happening within my home
and so the mayor is surely not
getting a proper representation of what
the
citizens of his city actually believe
and want because everybody is so busy
saying things designed to get the mob to
move on to someone else
that you get the wrong idea you get the
idea that portland is much more
supportive of the violence than it
actually
is and so what i'm hoping is that the
ability
that that our position as um
as unapologetic liberals who
uh believe that uh
coddling these violent anarchists is a
terrible terrible mistake and say so
repeatedly
that that is actually finally getting
through and that
in part what may have happened here is
that the mayor may be realizing
that there is more support for him doing
the right thing than he has understood
and while i'm very angry at all of the
violence that has happened
up till now if he has finally understood
this and he's going
uh to stick to enforcing the law
equally against all lawbreakers
then you know thank goodness and maybe
you know maybe we've hit bottom
yeah well it's always a dangerous thing
to imagine
you